okay let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here we are once
again welcome back to your favorite
podcast
and you know what i mean
wow
what's up everybody welcome back to
riven with griffin
chilled episode wiggy's back uh
you know i don't know what happened but
there he is oh there i am too
double double double up wiki's rusty on
the ones and twos but it's okay
we'll make it happen but welcome back to
riverwood griffin i got like uh
some reviews of a couple of things uh
black widows so spoiler alert on that
and just going to talk about warzone
because you guys know i played that a
lot on air griffin gaming and you know
but once again
welcome back to real family
[Laughter]
so welcome back kid everything good
yeah not too bad can't complain yeah we
could but nobody would listen right
exactly all right guys welcome back to
roofing with griffin and once again as
you know you can find me daily on twitch
at eric griffin gaming so make sure you
check me out on eric griffin gaming
and i got wiggy's information down there
too as you can see if you want to like
follow him he's got a lot of great
videos and stuff like there too to
check him out he's always working um and
uh you know
it's just been uh quite a uh quite a few
weeks
i'm not gonna get into the nba right now
the nba finals is going on and it's just
like you know it's phoenix versus the
bucks
you know now that i look at i'm just i'm
just not that interested so i'll wait
till we see who wins then i'll start
talking about that so there's that
and um you know it's just another
another week
you know the world the world uh i i've
been on f i went on fighter and the kid
uh that that went well i got i've gotten
a lot of feedback on that so i
appreciate all you fighter and the king
fans and everybody that shows up
actually to my gaming channel
when you see me on other podcasts uh so
i do appreciate that
got a funny video up that i did with the
very funny your name is nikki howard
uh so i got this like oil change video
so make sure you check that on her
profile
uh you know that's a funny video and uh
you know i'm in that the little guest
star and
you know i'm just trying to get myself
all over the place so you know we do it
so uh what's going on this week with me
i don't know man
you know what i was thinking about like
when you're in a relationship you know
being in a relationship is great because
you started doing things you didn't
think about before and it seems silly
but
like when you take a shower you fellas
out there
make sure you wash everything now we
always go for the big stuff
you know what i mean we wash our face
you know we wash genitals we wash our
butthole
under arms okay and then maybe we kind
of casually wash everything else
but when you with someone else there's
like other areas like for me it was like
behind the ears
so like i would wash my hair you know
maybe you wash your face
but sometimes you don't hit the back of
your neck and your ears but when you
like with
someone and you're cuddling with them
then they'll notice because they'll be
like ooh
something's something sour right here
so so i made sure to like i was like you
know what i gotta so now i had this
whole new routine you know
so not only you got to get the big three
or four you know you got to get belly
button
make sure you get in there you know soak
that up uh you know really
your legs whatever areas especially if
you like whatever freaky positions you
do
in the bedroom wherever their face is
going to be it might be in some weird
spot that you don't think that you need
to scrub down so
real world advice from a grown-ass man
is you know wash yourself
you know get behind the ears and all
that kind of stuff
like this is a weird spot you know you
know people your girl likes to kiss
right there
that she might be like oh is this what's
that sourness so i i've been like really
this i just thought about this it was
like from before like when we first
rachel first moved in
you know she was she very nicely brought
up hey are you washing
[Laughter]
you know and i was like way fatter than
too so that was like you know when you
when you big you got creases in areas
that you don't realize you need to clean
so this is probably a tmi section of the
podcast but
it is it is what it is so let me talk
about this you know
i never talk about this on riffenwood
griffin but you know i play
with call of duty all the time i love
call of duty i play call of duty war
zone
i really just got into the first person
shooters very uh recently i mean i used
to play destiny all the time
but this i've never played call of duty
the way i play it right now like i
literally play call of duty every day
i love warzone it's such a challenging
game i love how challenging it is
it's just you know you start with 150
people and in a circle closes and you
bowl down to one person
and when you get that victory after
spending 20 25 minutes playing the game
whoo it's uh it's it's just it's
i don't i can't explain you have the
highest of highs at the lowest of lows
very
it's all over the place emotionally but
what's happening
right now in uh war zone right now is
they're having a call of duty themselves
is having a lot of problems with
cheaters
like so the other day i put a video up
on tech talk and check me out on tech
talk eric griffin gaming
on tick tock my tick tock's blowing up
it's soft blowing up
because i had nothing on there then i
put a couple of gaming videos on there
and i have one that has like 600 000
views and i was like what
i don't get it like i literally before i
even go into warzone i was like i'm
glad wiggy's here because this is your
generation man
i don't get what makes
a video blow up like i don't get what
makes something viral
like i don't get why a certain
generation
picks up on this certain video and they
go oh we really like this and now
a million it has a million views like i
like there doesn't seem to be like a
formula it doesn't seem to be like if
you do this this and this everybody will
like it
it's so random like so these videos i've
been putting up like the videos i think
that i would get a lot of views don't
and then i'll put up some random thing
about
something that happened in the game and
the next thing you know that one gets
like a bunch of views
and so i just i i i don't know i'm
trying i feel old
so i'm trying to just like let me you
know what let me uh
you know what i'm saying wigs yeah
that's what i'm asking you that seems to
be
what happens with everybody though right
it's like the least the thing you've
like put the least amount of effort into
and just threw up is gonna get
the most views i don't know that's that
tends to be how it happens but sometimes
you get a you can like calculate it and
well is there a formula do you think do
you think like some of these take
like like forget the girls yeah because
there's a formula to that i mean the
girls like that's so simple it's just
be hot as hell and like you know dance
like
like you know somebody go gator she
dancing
like a streamer you know what i mean
like i get that
like there's just bad [ __ ] galore on
tick tock you know they don't i showed
wiggy this one
i didn't i didn't get it because the
girls just all she did is just like
she's
just but she bad she didn't even do
anything she's just like
she's not doing anything but like just
like stood there not even like a movie
yeah like nothing she just sit there and
went like this
she like slowly just like kind of like
turned towards the camera yeah
and she got 90 000 90 000 views like
nothing and then like a million
million views following that account but
anyway my point is
so so we know the formula for that and i
think it's the same way for guys too
uh right like the third strap the swoop
this
exactly so there's a thirst trap formula
is that what is that what you would call
it yeah
there's definitely a thirst trap formula
and yeah i mean that is
i feel like you can well it's one it's
super easy and
takes no effort but to uh you can also
like
for you okay well if that's the genre
that we're talking about yeah
because you have because you'll be
trying to do that too right do you
consciously do that you have like a
thirst trap
first trap pictures on your uh instagram
probably but it
but i i also just like you're gonna
hate on me for this but i just don't you
know i look good sometimes and
gotta post that one okay but i'll get
pizza
but i don't always look good but uh oh
my god
you sound like rachel i don't always
look good sometimes my swoop is like a
little bit off to the left
you know i'm getting i'm getting better
at just not caring
but uh oh what a world what a life you
know but for me
i saw okay so you got the thirst trap
formula but for the other stuff
i don't know yeah i don't know if
they're the dancing formula right
there's the dancing ones yeah it's like
not even great dancing no no i mean that
kind of goes in with the thirst straps i
feel like
okay got you right you're right you're
right you're right no but not always not
always you're right
well no well then there's the difference
between like talented dancers and then
like
first trappy stupid uh right like fake
dance moves where you're like you're
still being sexy
[Laughter]
uh like somebody clipped that
but uh yeah all right okay well we got
we got the
but as for a formula about like gaming
clips and stuff
i mean yeah i don't know if there is one
exactly it's just
whatever's funny is funny and if if it
catches it
i don't know if it actually has to do
okay so there is
funny there's like one cause i cuz i put
up one that was just funny the guy
i get why people liked it you know so i
dropped in
i killed a guy and then on the one of
my favorite things on warzone is the
killcoms so like when you kill
someone for three or four seconds the
mics are open on both sides
so the guy was like you know he goes he
goes you camping [ __ ] i'm coming back
for you
you know and i was like you know then i
it's just my reaction to what he was
saying was funny
and then he came back and i and i had
set up minds for him and he it blew him
up
so i get why people thought you know it
was like and i was like yeah that's a
great one yeah
oh this is kind of cool so i'm trying to
find more things like that but sometimes
i don't know what you know i
i put one up the other day it was like i
had it on instagram a long time ago so i
said let me put it on tick tock
it was like rachel comes in and then she
like puts her shirt over my head
you know and i'm like morning titties
you know
yeah put that up for sure i did but it's
it's not doing too long
so you never know but with with tick
tock it seems like it's definitely just
quantity over quality at this point you
know all right you just kind of like i
got to keep putting up a video
gotta like shovel them on there and all
right
all right yeah i lost all my traction on
my tic toc because i just
yeah that's what i'm trying to be
consistent with the gaming clip so we'll
see what happens
but anyways when i play um
warzone so the thing that is a real
prevalent problem on call of duty right
now is
cheating and hacking so i had this video
up that i put up on um
um what do you call it tick tock
and i put it on instagram i even put it
on is uh is this video
of uh me getting killed by a hacker
now there's this great dude his name is
jay god uh he
yes you can see it right here i i shoot
at the guy okay
and then all of a sudden i just die
right and then you look at the kill cam
and look what the guy does he's got a
hack you know
so he just fires just randomly and he
kills me like that
and the guys got like 41 kills at the
time
51 k 47 kills so that lets you
that's and he's got 20 people looking at
him so he is clearly
you know he is clearly um cheating you
know he's cheating so he's using a hack
he's using like uh you know on the pc
they have like these like aimbot apps
that help you
and these like and it's ridiculous but
it's becoming a problem
it's like like every game you you you
start to run into like one or two of
them
you know in either every game or every
other game you go
and then the problem with it too is like
there are really skilled players out
there
so what happens is the skilled players
they
um you know because they don't do
anything about the cheating because they
don't have an anti-cheat the skilled
players
you're always questioning like so you
get killed you're always like well this
is suspect
you always feel like oh man i don't i
don't know about this this seems like
somebody you know this seems like a
cheater
you know so you're always you know
accusing somebody of cheating
even though they may not be cheating
because activision treyarch and the
people that make call of duty
will refuse to do anything about this
problem and it really is a big problem
and it's like you know you invest a lot
of time in playing the game
i know it's for you people out there to
think video games are terrible and you
don't like playing them but
regardless even if you do you're
investing a lot of time like when you
play
warzone like i said you're dropping in
with 150 people
if you're down to the final 10 this has
been 20
25 minutes of your life then you get to
a certain point like i did in that game
i had like nine kills
i was moving and grooving and um
you know i died of some guy cheating you
know you it makes you upset
and it doesn't seem like activision
cares
like they keep putting out these
announcements of like oh we banned 400
000 people you know they keep saying
that they go oh they banned 400 000
people
in you know these accounts but it
doesn't seem like that's enough like
there has to be some sort of
uh there has to be some sort of freaking
anti-cheat other other things have that
you know oh here's an update right now
okay here we go
an update regarding call of duty
anti-cheat programs they're saying
you know they're they're talking about
weekly back-end security updates but
what is that
i don't even understand how it works
then they're talking about having in
addition we're increasing our efforts
and capabilities in these key areas
enhanced to our internal anti-cheat
software so they're claiming that they
have anti-cheat software
but i don't believe it because if they
do and i need somebody out there if
there's
some programming expert who can explain
to me
how these cheats work because i don't
understand why they can't
figure it out like why like why can't
they just come up with a program that
if anything's interacting with the
actual program itself
you know it it kicks them from the
server or
it sends like a little a notification or
something but i don't know but
you know i'm looking at this website
that you know wig has up for me right
now and it's like
they're talking about additional
detection technology adding new
resources dedicated to monitoring
enforcement
regular communication updates and
programs more two-way dialogue zero
tolerance for
cheat providers like i
there's a there's a um there's a
conspiracy
out there that activision
that these people that make the game
that they don't care
about that they don't care about the
cheaters and they're actually in cahoots
with the cheat companies
like maybe they're getting like a
kickback or something and you look at
that one right there it says
undetectable cheat like there's that one
right there
undetectable console cheat you know i
got
you know it's like so first okay so
first the complaint was
pc players are the ones doing all the
cheating
that was like the first thing they were
like oh i stole the pc players because
they got the
those like those little add-on
applications on the on the on the
computer
but then i come to find out that there's
a bunch of ways
to cheat with an xbox or ps4
so that made me just be like well then
there's no hope
you know there's just no hope so they
have this device
called a cronus device that's what it's
called it's like this
uh this thing you can buy
you know you see you see it right there
it's like like yeah you can
and they're sold out all the time yeah
it's called a cronus
max you know you know the chrono and
it's like
this you could just buy this stuff and
it like helps you look at look at rap
look at these are the features of the of
the cronus thing that you can use on
your
xbox or ps4 rapid fire
anti-recoil drop shot jitters
takes away that auto sprint fast reload
aim assist
sniper breath quick scope these are all
things that happen to you when you're
playing the game like you get quick
scope from someone and when you when you
do
you're thinking to yourself well is that
because this person is cheating
like it's craziness that they have these
things like this is a whole website this
cronus
website man and people are using this
it's a rampant problem
and the thing is with call of duty you
know they have tournaments
they they have like major tournaments
for
a lot of money on the line people are
playing this
and people are using these cheats
now now go down for a second there again
cause i i just noticed it says
battlefield see look at that
they even have cheats for the old
battlefield games so this new
battlefield is coming out
like the new battlefield is coming out
and people think well everybody's going
to move to battlefield because
everybody's cheating in warzone
but when i look at this cronus website
it looks to me
like you could cheat in any game you
want
they they show it right here anthem apex
legends
battlefield borderlands they're showing
how this cronus device helps you
with all of these games every single
call of duty
even destiny a game that i used to play
all the time so it seems to me that
there's
no there's no escape from people wanting
to cheat
and i don't understand why people
cheated a game i mean it's so
challenging and fun and don't you want
to like
win like because like when people cheat
you freaking know they cheated because
you could see it like you know they're
not hiding it if you're in a solo game
and you have
50 kills you're cheating you know
and you can then like there's 20 people
watching and at the end of the game
everybody's yelling at them and calling
them like swear words and you know
derogatory terms because everybody is so
mad but
i don't know so it's like shout out to
activision shout out to actually all
these game companies look man
you got to do something about the
cheating especially if
gaming is going to be considered a sport
per se
you know when you have esports so you
have e-gaming and this is a big thing
people like to watch
the integrity of the game is important
and there's so many websites who that
are offering
tournaments you know i was in one i got
in one where like you know you
you get a certain amount of kills if you
get a certain amount of wins
you can you win money it's cash prizes
on the line
so that means that the integrity of the
match
has to be 100 and people
are out here they don't care and they're
cheating and the companies
don't seem to care so that is just
really
frustrating so like again i say shout
out to uh
any computer programmers out there uh
anybody that really understands how this
thing works i would really like you to
hit me up
hit me up email me eric errorgriffin.com
or you know
you know hit me up on the instagram dms
i see those
um and then let me know like if you want
to explain to me how it happens
then i'll have an episode i might even
like you know
have you uh re remotely come in you know
zoom in on the
on the pocket just so i can ask them
like i would love to ask a
computer nerd how this works and is
there
is there a way to stop it because some
people are saying there actually is no
way to stop it
look you can go right to amazon right
now cronus max plus
cross cover gaming adapter for ps4 ps3
xbox one 360 windows pcs it's like 119
you plug it right into your thing and
you get all of this
cheating capability so i just that's
kind of cool
you why why is that cool i'm kidding but
uh
that's just crazy it reminds me of when
i used to play pokemon and
like do the um oh what's it called like
the
you plug in a guy to the you put it in
the cartridge and then you put the game
into the guy it was like
like a game freak or something like that
not a game for you also was it like a
enhancement yeah it was the same similar
type of thing where you could like catch
any pokemon well if you can
yeah so it's basically cheating you know
but it's like way to enhance so
you know there's so many uh of these
things out there like it's they're just
they're just
all over amazon people are just you know
using these things
you just go man come on man have some
integrity like you know we don't want
this
but anyways that's that about what i
wanted to talk about that
um so that's going to get into this
other thing um
you might want to look this up two wigs
on to show even on the screen but
there's a new season of gossip girl okay
there's a new season
the only reason why i know about gossip
girl is rachel moves in
and when we're in the pandy and we're
just watching stuff and i'm just sitting
there watching what she's watching
and she is watching she is binge
watching
gossip girl okay and
it is terrible okay i just
i'm not no shame in my game right now
i'm talking about
terrible it's just
a ton of white beautiful ass
actors and actresses being
terrible remember don't show up for too
long because then they'll ding me
they for some reason they don't just
ding for sound anymore now
they even ding for video right they can
register the yeah they can register the
video it's really weird
but so this is the new season of gossip
girl that's out but let me talk about
the old season of gossip girl for a
second so the old season of gossip girl
it's um like i said blake lively was on
it
it was just like it's just it's just
like a a young person
soap opera of just drama and pretty
people being pretty doing pretty things
they're rich they're white they're this
and that okay
whatever you know what i mean and so
that was on for i don't know how many
seasons you know it's just one of those
shows like like
in my era it would be the new beverly
hills it would no 90210
like that was the big one when i was
like young everybody was watching 902 a
melrose place and those kinds of shows
it was like that kind of show you know
and like i said it was very it looked
and i and by the way
even though i say this when i say it's
very white
i'm not saying that disparagingly i i
it just it is what it is it's a it's
it's about
a affluent white community it's like a
private school or whatever
and it was just like you know look just
white people being white you know what i
mean
and they and they were um you know and
they and they were just i get it
this is their circle of people like like
not everything has to be diversified
okay this is the point i'm trying to
make
you don't always have to make things
diverse just to make it diverse
if you're if you're doing a show about
some white people doing some white [ __ ]
i'm okay with that i'll enjoy it like we
don't have to have everything be like
well
we need to do this you know now that
being said and this is why i'm talking
about this
so rachel's excited about the new season
of gossip curl and i turn it on
and that's a perfect picture right there
that picture right there is
perfect when you see the new season of
gossip girl
it is woke as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like look at it like they were like okay
we're gonna do the new season of gossip
girl and let's make sure we have
as diverse a cast as possible
and i'm like okay like here's the thing
it's gonna take us a while to weed out
the these kinds of feelings it's gonna
take us a while
you know i always like talking about
sports as an example of this
so when you look back to baseball and
they allowed
jackie robinson to enter baseball he was
the first black player to play in the
in the white league okay or the indian
you know whatever it was all white
so they let this black person play now
when they did that
it didn't mean that everybody that
watched baseball all of a sudden
liked black people you know what i mean
it was a money play too by the way they
were like look we got all these
you know the negro leagues or they got
all these people selling tickets let's
get everybody to come
you know let's just bring them here so
we can make money here you know
so you know what i mean
so it's like um that's if i wanna do it
live dude we gotta like
you know you gotta move that one yeah we
do yeah you just because i i kept them
on the far left for you
it's just the the left three yeah yeah
that's the only ones you need
but anyways um so you know it took a
while
it took a while until it took 100 years
basically
for like now we have the league but you
know ironically there are barely any
black players playing baseball anymore
but that's a whole
other story that i think that just has
to do with how baseball
wasn't you know baseball is an expensive
sport you know it's not like basketball
you know
you know all you need is a ball you need
five dudes six dudes
two dudes really you can play one-on-one
and you don't need much equipment you
don't need a field that has to be up
kept i mean it's like
they didn't do i think major league
baseball didn't do enough in the urban
communities in the in the
places to help push their sport to the
those types of people and so now 20
years later you're looking at it and you
wonder why
it's all latin american people playing
and we need to just put
you know lee uh teams franchises in
those countries
you know we need to just have the
mexican uh you know whatever team the el
salvadorian team the
make that part of the you know you know
whatever but who knows whatever
either way so i'm saying so you cut to
this you know it took a while but then
we
we become familiar with you know having
diversity in the sport so it's at a
point where you don't even think about
it anymore really
even though people still mention it but
you don't really think about it well
that's so right now
in tv we're dealing with the jackie
robinson sort of thing that's happening
right now where it's like
we gotta make everything diverse so
let's take a show like gossip girl that
was about a rich white private school
or wherever they went about you know
some wealthy white people and now we
let's do it again but let's make it now
you know rich uh multi-ethnic
like there's like a girl there's like a
bald girl with who's racially ambiguous
who has like a mixed
sister who like you know you know it's
like is she black we're not sure
you know you have like all these
different types and sizes and
colors and of course there's still a
really hot white guy and a blonde girl
with blue eyes you're always going to
have that they're like we're not going
to get rid of that
you know we still don't have that but
it's like you know you look at it and
right now you're still at a point where
you're just kind of like
okay i see what you're doing
you know it's like all right yeah you
know
and then you know and then it's like so
it's really about rich people being
awful
so then it's like now you got rich
ethnic people being awful
i don't know if i want to see that i
actually like watching
i like watching rich white people be
terrible to each other
i like that that's like that's a fun
thing to watch
just snotty rich white people being
snotty to each other it's okay
you know so now you're just saying like
okay there's also rich snotty
you know mixed mixed-race people too but
it's like okay
so right now we're gonna be we're living
in an era where we're gonna see it and
we're always gonna like have a feeling
like uh
and maybe me more so than some younger
people too you know
it's like you're here wigs it's like you
know you're you know you're a different
generation
like when you look at things is race a
thing for you
do you even think about it or are you
just so cause like your age
you know like you're 24 right yeah so
you're 24
so like four years ago okay you were 20
yeah so like when you were 12
13 you had a black president you know so
yeah
so to you you know you're just like oh
yeah you know i have black friends
you know this and rap music and you know
like it's like
it's probably no big deal to you but for
me my generation
uh you know it is a big deal to see
certain things and we still
we're one foot in the past of thinking
about like ah this country did this and
that
but like when you see a show like gossip
girl when you see that
not that you would look at that but if
you did when you see that
does it make you feel anything at all
when you see like the diversity do you
think about it at all
i mean i think about like
when i'll see uh i mean yeah i would
definitely like
if this is my first i can't find the
picture but uh
if if that was my first like like oh new
gossip girl and this is what the cast
looks like
i'm kind of obviously gonna know i mean
that they're just they're reaching
a little bit for diversity oh okay so
that is something that even
like i notice it but um
definitely less than say a lot of stuff
skims over my head but like
like maybe in like an advertisement when
they're hi they'll have like a
super like a asian woman and a black guy
as like the couple and it's like
and then there's like an indian guy
that's playing this other like
i'll be like okay they're just like
really okay see that's interesting
okay that's it thank you voice thank you
so that's interesting so that
is exactly what i'm talking about so
right now
we're still at a point where
we're noticing it so we're just we're
we're
you know we're five to ten years away
for well that's it's gonna be the norm
we're gonna normalize it
but right now we're living in that era
where we're very much like
something comes out and we kind of go
here they go you know there they go
again they're trying to do this
you know and so and you know that it has
to happen it's part of the growing pains
of diversity
it's part of the growing pains of you
know making
i guess making the world a better place
if that's uh you know if that's such a
thing
but you know but yeah and they did the
guy with like the dyed hair
that's what i'm saying but he's also
like very ambiguously like he could be
anything
like i noticed with this gossip girl
class which i kind of like
this gossip girl cat gossip girl cast
this is like these all could be my kids
yeah true you know what i mean they all
could be my kids like you know i'd say
so
that that was the the darker black uh
wife who you know i had a baby with that
you know what i mean and she would look
like that
you know then this is like oh the asian
girl the sort of filipino
asian girl that you know what i mean and
we had him you know what i mean
uh i adopted this white girl
this girl she could be my daughter you
know what i mean
he's just a yeah i don't know she can
she you know you know what i mean like
it's like it's all like
that kind of thing because you know the
world is going to start looking more
brown so
but anyways i'm not trying to be like
all race race based it's not about that
guys it's just about the
i'm just pointing out the transition
that in our minds it's prevalent even if
you don't want it to
be but you know there is still a part of
us that when we see this so here's the
new gossip girl like oh look that's a
perfect picture of the cast
it's like here's the new gossip girl and
you're just kind of like oh
okay i see what's going on here you know
and you just go okay
all right so we just need more shows
like that and then it keep happening and
happening and we won't
we won't worry about it any more i think
i don't know we'll see you guys tell me
in the comments
yeah that's a great picture right there
of like the the new cast and you could
just see you know it's like
you know and it's like always like
something about them too is like you
know
maybe one's lesbian or one's like
non-binary
yeah so that kind of stuff too that's
that's added on to the race stuff
now so it's not only do you like it's
like we can't just have things be all
white
that's the feeling that you're getting
can be all white even though i
personally don't mind that
i don't need everything to be diverse
you know sometimes like i say i want to
watch white people doing white [ __ ]
you know what i mean i just like that
sometimes you know what i mean uh
in the same way that i like watching
like you know there'll be a show where
it's like this is black people being
black you know i like that too
you know sometimes that's okay to have
those and at the same time you want to
have some
oh these are all everybody's interacting
with each other too but you know
it is what it is so not only do you have
to worry about now where it's like
all right you have to make sure that you
have you're you're racially diverse
now it's all about pronouns and you know
that's another factor in it too like
sometimes you watch a show
like here's one you'll watch a show and
then like
in that show there'll be a kid in the
show
and that kid in the show is going
through this thing of like
it's a girl who now wants to be a boy or
a boy who wants to be a girl like i see
that all the time in the show
so when you see that you just go damn
they making it seem like this is like
everywhere
you know like you know and so you know
you just go okay okay i get it you're
still you're trying to
you're pushing this too so it's like
there's so much of that going on right
now
and like i just think that we like we're
very sensitive to it right now
as soon as we see it we just go oh yeah
there we go
you know i don't know you guys tell me
what you think in the comments
because you guys love sending comments
you know i got just i was on fire and
the kid and this guy
wrote me like like three paragraphs on
instagram like [ __ ] i'm not
gonna read
three paragraphs on instagram you know
what i mean
like who are you with your novel like if
you can't get to your point
like you know like just get to your
point because we're not you don't know
me like that
you know i just ah guys just like check
in with me first this is what i'm trying
to say
you know it's like when you're texting
with your girl
if you're like if if if rachel has
something to tell me that's super
important
i like for her to check in hey can you
talk right now give me a check-in text
hey what's up i need to talk to you
about something then i can go
okay and now i'm ready for it i can't
stand when people send
like paragraph text of important [ __ ]
and then you write back
okay that's all you have to say
you know what i mean that's all you just
say is okay like
first of all i didn't want to have this
conversation you can't just drop an
important conversation on me and expect
me to okay now i have to be invested in
your important conversation
you got to give me a second i need a
check-in okay i need a check-in
so i don't even know why i'm even
talking about that
but that's just my bitchin with
griffin's segment i guess
you know that's what i like to do um all
right what else do i got for you
all right uh so yeah check out gossip
girl i don't know i mean i i watch
i'm sitting there with rachel and it's
on and then she goes i know you like
this and i'm like i don't like it you
know
and then i stay for the whole show
uh but okay so i want to talk about a
movie now this is like the
latest movie that just came out from the
mcu you know i'm a marvel nerd i love
avengers i love all that stuff and so
here we are with black widow spoiler
alert i'm
gonna try not to spoil the movie but if
you want to watch it
without listening to my review this is
the time to get off and thank you for
listening to riverwood griffin
just get out of my face all right so
here we go black widow so we all know
black widow is dead
uh from the avengers and game spoiler
alert all right
she died in end game so this is sort of
a prequel
but when i finish the movie i'll tell
you this is this isn't spoiling anything
this movie comes right after civil war
right before infinity stones the the
first avengers of the you know whatever
it was called infinity war
whatever that whatever that one was this
is that time
in between this is what black widow was
doing when
steve rogers and uh the falcon
busted you know witcher soldier out of
jail
out of that max prison that tony stark
made they but and this is them on the
run
from you know the government
because you know now he's on the run
okay so
this is what what she was doing during
that time
but i got to tell you this is just me
but this was a great movie like i really
enjoyed black widow
and i enjoyed it for the acting i
enjoyed that they brought
the sensitivity that was happening
when you have women in an action movie
setting
like it really is like it really did
enhance it
but like scarlett johansson is a great
actress and the other chicks that were
in the movie
really good and the main guy hey pull up
the imdb so i can know who the hell
these people's names are
you know um black widow imdb
you know the it was really well done
so and what they did um
there it is right there right that's
wikipedia
oh wikipedia peter's good yeah give imdb
there we go we got uh
scarlett johansson florence pugh david
harbor oh yeah that's better that's
better perk yeah david harbour was great
david harbor was great uh scholar
johansson was great the other chick
florence
pugh never seen her before she was great
rachel wise was great
and i love how she's like playing like
the mom now
you know what i mean like she's like but
she still looks banging like she was
great in it um
all these people were great so you get a
little taste
of black widow's past you know she's
this world-class assassin and you know
she was
a part of like a russian infiltration
thing and you already know this if you
know the lore and you they've kind of
hinted towards it in the past of some
other movies
and this is kind of like they do a
little flashback and they show her as a
child and you kind of get like
how she got in the program and who these
people are
and then like you know cut to some years
later you know there's a plot and she
has to like you know
there's this rush there's this sort of
russian
underground you know uh sort of like spy
organization
though they're the enemies and you know
there's mind control involved and
there's like you know
you know what i mean it's that kind of
like illuminati type subplot going on
that you can easily follow
but the interaction of these peoples was
great you know
just like you you believed everything
that happened to them and it's just a
testament to the performances of these
actors and actresses
excuse me it was really good and the
action was phenomenal too so if you need
your action fix
it's really great uh just the stuff that
was happening and the special effects
and i just thought
excuse me mcu for the win again you know
get something to drink here yeah mcu for
the win again man
so shout out to lollipop
i really love this new drink i don't
know if you guys ever had it it's
lollipop it's really low in
sugar and calories this is only 35
calories and it supports digestive
health you know
you know what before i even go on from
finishing with black widow
actually i got to do an ad for you guys
right now i got to talk about our
special ad
for better betterhelp.com griffin
a great sponsor of the show uh if you
need if you need therapy
uh you know i listen i highly recommend
therapy
i really do it really does help you get
to the some core issues
really helps you connect the dots to why
you feel the way you feel if you're
feeling stressed you're feeling anxiety
you're having like trouble sleeping like
all the different issues
you get with a trained professional
because this isn't self-help they're
trained professionals
and they'll help you you they'll help
you pinpoint because they recognize
patterns and then they'll help you like
see that oh this might be because of
your parents so this might be because
you feel this way or that way
and it really helps you you know
fight that those feelings that you have
and really have some coping mechanisms
to like
make yourself feel better act better
live better i want you to live a happy
life
uh you know and better help is a way to
do that uh
they they're adding new counselors all
the time and like i say this isn't
self-help it really is
professional counselors you don't have
to go into a stupid office anymore you
do it from the comfort of your own home
it's very affordable and i highly
recommend it and i want you to start
living a happier life today
and as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
griffin join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
griffin for 10 off your first
month better help all right
yeah uh these people in the black widow
movie they needed better help you know
because imagine if you like you're
you're a trained assassin you've grown
up as an assassin
they took out your uterus because they
don't want you to have a family because
they want you to be a killer for the
rest of your life
i mean that kind of person needs uh
mental help
so they needed that so uh and the young
actors too that played the young
versions of uh
them were really good it was uh it was
really good
um yeah wiggy's just you you're just
these are just
you're all you need is the the
those three oh you're right i'm rusty
you're rusty man
[ __ ] so um i do recommend it so
like again the movie opens up they show
a little flashback of the past
uh and then it just cut forward to you
know right after like the sokovia
accords and
you know the wakandan king was killed
and like all that stuff had just
happened and she's on the run
and then you you kind of see like her
and i love the mcu i love that they do
this
you know and then and then and then you
have to watch
i highly recommend you have to stay with
the credits they do that mcu thing
where there's some stuff in the credits
that that kind of like
teases what's happening and i don't know
if they're teasing
this is the great thing about it i don't
know if they're teasing a movie or if
they're teasing the tv show
uh you know some with some more tv shows
that are coming up because loki's still
on and it's going strong and i love it
i love loki so much so you know and
there's something that happened in the
so there's a person that was in the
captain america not captain america
falcon and winter soldier show there's a
guest star
person in that that they show in this
too and which combines all the worlds
you know everything's still combined so
you don't know if they're gonna be
for like if this is gonna be for season
two of falcon winter soldier
you don't know if this is gonna be for
like the new the the hawkeye
show that's coming out you don't know if
it's gonna be for like uh you know
you know black widow part two maybe or
maybe maybe somehow they find a way to
bring her back or
like one of her sisters takes over as
black widow you never know it's like
it's
very you know what i mean i i love
all the little intrigues that are going
on all the little teasing and little
like hey this is going on so make sure
you check that out
so that was just one of the you know one
of the
amazing elements of the the movie and
what the mtu is doing i think marvel's
doing a really fantastic
job they are blowing
dc out of the water man like dc
get your [ __ ] together
you know like i uh i used to have dc
universe they got rid of dc universe's
streaming service and
there was a show titans on there and it
was like this rated r
version of it was rated r you know it's
like so like it was about robin
and the teen titans he's creating the
team titans and it was great
well they're coming out with of course
a cw version with the same actors
and i believe it's a continuation of
you know the the series that was on dc
universe and you can also see it on html
max
but now that it's like on tv
i'm out cause now it's gonna be pg-13
i love the cursing and the sex and the
gore and the violence
i'm an adult i want to see adult [ __ ]
i'm tired of pg-13 stuff man
i that's why i liked uh what was the one
with uh
oh my god uh not daredevil what is what
oh deadpool deadpool thank you my music
my memory
deadpool is a great marvel universe
movie but it's more under the sony
branch but i think that they're gonna
bring it all in but like yeah deadpool
was great it was rated r man
it was just great it was a good i like
the language i like the sex i like the
violence
i like adult stuff man you know what i
just watched for the first time i'm
super late on
is um kick ass kick ass was another one
that was like
you know uh totally on that in that
sailing it almost
like inspired deadpool kind of or just
that like
that gory like but also cattle like
light-hearted comedy
kind of yeah that's adult humor yeah we
want
adult humor i think it's part of the
reason why people listen sometimes
people listen to podcasts
instead of listening to say the radio
because like you know it's going to be
some like you know
like a 75 ads even though some podcasts
have 35 as i don't maybe i have two at
the most sometimes three
but that's what i'm doing makeups but
like you know
you listen to podcasts cause you get
kind of get a raw unfiltered you
feel like this is some raw unfiltered
emotions and i think we like that in
movies too i think we like
watching rated r movies you know we like
you know it's and it's not just about
seeing titties and all this kind of
stuff
so much of it is about like just the
possibility that you could
is there you know for me i don't want
any ratings i would love to just see i
like i love that's why i think the
korean movies are the best
when you watch some of those korean
martial arts movies
i mean oh like if you oh man if you
watch
um uh raid you guys got to watch the
raid
the raid and raid 2 raid redemption and
raid 2
oh my god those are some of the best
action movies ever and it's violent and
gory and like the knife like the knife
goes in and he just [ __ ]
slices through someone like i love all
that kind of stuff i like things that
make you go
you know what i mean that's the good
[ __ ] right there you know that's the
good [ __ ]
all right guys uh you know what i know
i know i know he's like how to do this
you know i could do this wigs check this
out we can make this
even easier wait i'm not doing it right
i'm messing up
now i'm messing up yeah but i could do
it like this
yeah yeah so anyways guys
i really appreciate you watching uh
griffin with griffin
uh this is the one that's short and
sweet i think i'm a guy got real world
advice from a grown ass man coming back
next week
wigs is gonna come with some of those
like i don't know if there's the tic tac
videos
he's gonna figure something out that you
know so he can like pull his own weight
here
yeah we had a lazy week uh but you know
we're here so make sure you check out
black widow
uh make sure you check out gossip girl
too check that out so you can see how it
makes you feel
remember you computer programmers out
there hit me up on instagram
let me know if you can explain to me how
this cheating works
and again if you believe there's
anything that can be done about it
make sure you check me out on uh gaming
channel eric griffin gaming
um i'm there daily and you know
wigs thanks for being for being here
again unless you know we'll keep it
moving
we're working on something we're gonna
try to do a music video for my riffing
mcgriffin theme
we got some stuff in the works so look
out for that and i know with the patreon
i'm sorry i'm i'm going to do some more
patreon content i swear to you
rachel has been taking some videos of
like because it was like uh
um what did she call it uh engagement
week
you know what i mean oh that's right i
forgot to talk about that i actually did
it guys i i
gave her the ring so now maybe i'll show
you some pictures of that yeah i'll shut
your
look who's talking don't bring your
business up
anyways so we made that happen so i'll
keep you posted on that next week but
anyways
this has been real for mcgriffin thanks
again and see you next
week
you